well if you love movies this next guy is
a big reason why super producer Jerry
Bruckheimer Top Gun Flashdance Beverly
Hills top bad boys Pirates of the
Caribbean you want me to keep going I
can he has produced so many blockbusters
it's actually taking the entire month of
April to pay tribute to him with a big
movie festival at UCLA
when they tell you we're gonna honor you
for an entire month
what do you say it means I've made too
many movies
that's what it is many but not too many
Jerry after all your hits have totaled
an astounding ten point seven billion in
worldwide box office dollars satisfied
do you ever sit back and say holy cow
I have really been working but I don't
because I'm always looking forward to
the next one so you know we just
finished another Pirates so I always
look to the future also in the works a
new Top Gun you posted a picture of you
and Tom Cruise on Twitter will he come
back yeah of course you don't make Top
Gun without Tom Cruise no word on
whether Mavericks nemesis Val Kilmer is
on board you're everyone's problem you
know there were all those rumors that
Tom and Val did not get along on the say
but that truth no they got along fine
that's not true
bad boys bad boys there's also a new bad
boys in the mix will wants to do what
Martin wants to do it we'd see will and
Martin back together one more time of
course I wouldn't do it any other way is
there gonna be another Beverly Hills we
hope so we repent discussions with Eddie
in paramount they're all excited about
doing it due next May Johnny Depp in his
fifth go round as Captain Jack oh my
gosh we were in Australia he went to the
hospital and visit all his terminally
ill kids as Jack Sparrow
he carries the costume in a trunk and
whatever he goes to a city he will make
sure he visits the Children's Hospital a
key to Jerry's success can be found in
the film Armageddon when he sent his
young writer JJ Abrams to research our
space I said so I had this meeting and
there wouldn't be this seismic activity
on the asteroid there would be no
explosions on it you know I went this on
this list of things and Jerry said nano
keep it safe so it didn't matter that's
kind of what Jerry told us when we
visited the set back in 1998 this
asteroid is barreling towards Earth
we're gonna catch up with it
and land on it and then we're gonna
split it in half also on the set that
day 25 year old Ben Affleck Jerry was
really helpful to me
know anything about big Hollywood movies
Annie I was very intimidated and he
helped me along and it was a really
thrilling movie and experience for me
another thrilling movie for Jerry and
Ben what's Pearl Harbor but it's really
to honor the men fought there and died
there and then when we had the veterans
who were still alive we had a premiere
dad Pearl Harbor which was a fantastic
premiere just to see the joy that they
had and watching the movie and one
reason that we did him right and they
thanked us you know Jerry really lit up
when he was talking about making movies
honoring the men and women of the Armed
Forces it's really a passion of his he's
an amazing TV producer as well all the
CSI shows without a trace cold case and
Jerry has won ten Emmys for The Amazing
Race